You are doing awesome work.
To recap, let's talk a little
bit about what you've done.
So the first thing that you did is you
defined a rule structure at that mirrors
our actual database.
Then, using that rule structure,
you created validations for
both properties and entire objects.
Next we figured out what kind of read
and write rules that you need for
each root node.
And that's all been laid out for
you in a spec.
So now we're ready to actually implement
those rules, of course using those handy
UID mapping and
owner mapping rules that you just made.
But before I throw you in the wild
of writing read and write rules,
I wanted to give you a couple of tips
and tricks about troubleshooting.
Because you might be wondering,
how do you actually test
a rule when it's not working?
So my first tip is a oldie but
a goodie, and
it's basically to turn
on the debug mode.
This gives you access to
all sorts of good data.
In the case of a read,
it will show you the exact location
you're trying to read from.
And in the case of write, it'll show
you the exact data that you're sending
to the app, that might or
might not be getting denied.
In addition though, Firebase actually
provides you with a simulator to test
out reading and writing data.
And the simulator's pretty
cool because it allows you to
very clearly see what's
happening with your permissions.
Okay.
So, in the Firebase dashboard,
you can go ahead and go over to this
Simulator tab and, for our app,
because login is so important, you're
going to want to select a Custom Auth.
The provider doesn't,
matter but the UID does.
This will make it so that when
you're using your read/write rules,
in this case the provider
isn't important, but
you should put in a UID of
a pre-existing user in your app.
In my case, I'm going to go ahead and
put in UID.
And I just copied and
pasted this over from my data here,
where if you look at the UID mappings,
you can grab her UID.
Okay, so I put in UID, and
I can press Authenticate.
And this will basically make it so
I am impersonating.
And then, here, I can simulate
different read or write rules.
Write rules allow you to also specify
some data that you tring to write.
So, for example, if you wanted to
test that rule that you just created,
you could find a shopping list that
is shared on, another list that she's
the owner of, and finally a list
that she has nothing to do with, and
make sure that they all
give the correct responses.
So, for example, I'm going to get
a shopping list that is shared on.
So over here I'm looking at lists.
Okay, here's one that she shared on,
and it has the name K7J0.
So I'll go over here to shopping
list items, go to list K7J0,
and then I'll go ahead and
open that link in the other tab.
I'll copy this location, and
then over here in the simulator
I can put that location
that I just copied here.
So basically, I'm now doing a simulated
read for shopping list items for
that list that she was shared on.
Okay, and
I'm already authenticated as her.
So, I could come down here,
and I'm authenticated as.
I'm trying to read at this
list that she's shared on.
I can press simulate read, and
it says here that the read is allowed.
It even goes through each of
the rules of these different steps.
So you get a lot of output information
and it will tell you, actually, if there
are multiple rules along the path, which
one it passes and which one it fails.
So it's very useful.
And so, similarly, I can take
a list that she's not a part of,
which she's not a part of this list.
And I can simulate a read.
And it would show that
the read was denied, and
point out which of
these rules was false.
Finally, Bolt could be
a pretty helpful tool for
writing rules,
including read and write rules.
As I mentioned, checking whether
a user is shared on the list, or
the owner of a list,
is a fairly common rule.
You've also probably seen that
it's a little bit long to write.
Bolt allows you to write functions, and
then use those functions
in different places.
And this is, essentially,
gives you a pretty easy way to make
fairly similar rules in a bunch of
different parts of the rule stock.
So here's a quick example of a function
in Bolt, and I'm not going to go over
the semantics of all the [INAUDIBLE] to
some of the bolt documentation for that.
But, basically, it's doing the look
up in that UID mappings table
to get you the encoded email.
And here's another function, which when
passed in a ListID parameter, it goes
into the owner mappings node and gets
you back the owner email for that list.
And here's yet another function which
combines these two other functions
to get your encoded email and
compare it to the email of a list.
So, you might write up a bunch
of functions in Bolt, and
then in your paths part of your Bolt
file, you can write something like this.
And what this rule is
basically doing is saying,
for a list name in
a specific shopping list,
the owner of that shopping list is the
only one who can change the list name.
And while he had to write
all these functions,
you can now use this owner function
in as many places as you want.
So there might be ten places in the app
that you want to check for ownership.
All you have to do now is write
this isOwner function call.
A full explanation of writing
functions in Bolt is accessible in
the instructor notes, but
hopefully this is enough to prove to you
that using Bolt might be a good idea.
So now that you know the different
options for troubleshooting and
debugging your rules, do you think that
you could write the rest of the read,
write, and validate rules that I'm
giving you in the spec right now?